we are given a 30 60 90 triangle named
abc
it is right angled at vertex b
measure of angle a is 30 degrees
and angle c measures 60 degrees
what do we need to prove here
we have to prove that the side opposite
30 degrees is half the length of the
hypotenuse
that is
bc is equal to half ac
how do we prove that
this figure does not tell us anything
so we have to do a little bit of
construction to find a way out
let's extend cb to d like this
such that bc is equal to bd
this length should be equal to this
length
and then we join a d like this
because we've extended cb this angle
also will be 90 degrees
now let's analyze our construction
we are interested in length of bc
from our construction we know that bc is
equal to bd
it means that bc will be half of dc
so if we manage to prove dc equal to ac
we're done
in our proof let's look at triangle abc
and triangle abd
in these two triangles
bc is equal to bd based on our
construction
bc is equal to bd
angle abc is equal to angle abd as both
equal 90 degrees
and a b is equal to a b because it's the
common side to both the triangles
we have a side angle and side
therefore triangle abc is congruent to
triangle abd by the sas congruence
condition
the corresponding parts of congruent
triangles are always congruent
angle adb is equal to angle acb as their
corresponding angles of congruent
triangles
but we are given that angle acb is 60
degrees
it implies that angle adb will also be
60 degrees
angle bad will also be equal to angle
bac as they are corresponding angles of
congruent triangles
and angle bac is given as 30 degrees
which is why angle bad will also equal
30 degrees
both these angles together form angle a
so we get the measure of angle a as 60
degrees
now look at triangle adc
as all three angles equal 60 degrees
we can say that triangle adc is
equilateral
all sides of an equilateral triangle are
equal to each other
therefore dc will be equal to ac
we got what we were looking for
as b is the midpoint of segment dc dc
will be equal to twice bc
this equation can be written as 2 times
bc equals ac
transposing 2 to the other side
we get bc equals half ac
in a 30 60 90 triangle the length of the
side opposite the 30 degrees angle is
always half the length of the hypotenuse
does the converse also hold true
we see that in the coming videos
you